yes this is my final episode of the
lobby my final week here at GameSpot
calm new episode of the point coming up
on Friday I think maybe it's not the
point it's not GTA video I was working
on yeah did in New York was that that WW
thing I want to see that fun yeah yeah
hotshots that's c100 real girl for
taking shots of shots of friggin
buildings and stuff so I'm out - yeah
how you feeling - all right yeah it's
weird it's super weird cuz you're like
you're leaving the job that like [ __ ]
I mean we all worked really hard to like
work in this industry and like the
break-in in the first place he's like
I'd do anything for that job I do
anything for that job and then to like
walk away from it it's like a weird
thing it's like it's it feels like it
feels like running into danger like why
would I do this
but that's that's characteristic of I
think maybe some of the risks you took
to get this job in the first place right
and it panned out think of it yeah think
of it in terms of graduating rah that's
good I like that that's a good Spanish
game yeah yeah I guess it's been fired I
can't believe it's been five years yeah
how long you been living here living
here been working here almost five years
I'll be five years next month
it's nuts feels like I'd like it now I
was look I was looking on my my GameSpot
profiles like I think it I think I
started in 2005 I was like a lurker for
like two years
um and then I think I registered then so
I'm like almost working here as long as
I was registered I'm thinking about
working here yeah so that's yeah it's
pretty crazy it's great yeah it's gonna
be weird
Jean Luc's sitting on the corner and I
saw Mary looking like she was crying at
her desk earlier and now I'm worried
that there's like some sort of secret
montage situation it's just a me and Rob
coming up great great that would that
would definitely make me cry ah is this
it is this the thing that's happening
John who is it yeah all right let's do
it
roll that we did we can sweep it all
afterwards
[Music]
[Music]
the first game I ever completed was the
secret of monkey island on the Amiga 600
I was about seven and it took me three
months or TS RTS a Link to the Past it's
because his name is lei Jesus anyway I'm
Irish handling hot potatoes is kind of
my thing God Jesus Christ hello welcome
to random encounter the life's doing
shall we play it different random game
on Tuesdays and Thursdays timber this
level this had like incredible water
graphics oh yeah graphics thing look at
that move what's that what's their deep
roster buds 65-63 take that the
continent of Africa I mean if you are
there yeah now I'm freaked out and what
a good tiny monkey man here we go this
is it this is it this is it
find this later your mom no no this is
for Poland
Paris and purple for people who had that
mustache before you came around I made
it unfashionable so come buy a
PlayStation Portable today sure it costs
a month's wages but if the games are
bollocks
you could always watch porn on the bus
Oh welcome to the point though welcome
to the point low and welcome to the
point and if you're watching this on
GameSpot calm the brand-new website
Hey look at it it looks a lot shiny
clean and new and stuff and yeah you
guys are right it does kind of look like
giant bomb shoot games diverge away from
film or is David cage onto something
with beyond two souls are we just steps
away from being an interactive
storytelling medium it makes it more
understandable but it doesn't mean we
have to accept it online communities
have the ability to be so much more and
we all have a part to play hey there
this week on the point I've just
realized I've got a bunch of last gen
games I have a completed yet and it's
freaking me do the intro
[Music]
davide [ __ ] we can hang out every
Tuesday at 2 p.m. Pacific right here on
gamespot.com famous off gangs became a
diverse we asked John Travolta watch
Rambo specific the first name is
amazing oh my god you got microphone
idle neck tattoo it's weird that someone
is moving that I don't believe it
welcome vault dweller welcome to the
wasteland hello and welcome to the point
this week brought to you by the power of
the oculus rift a fantastic new device
owned by Facebook war depending on what
games you play it's either changed
irrevocably or it never changes at all
so the one thing you don't want to feel
when you're partying with $60 of your
hard-earned cash is that you're getting
some truncated version of the full game
and guess what when you launch a game
with that much optional content that's
how people are gonna feel if you watch
the point frequently then you know the
one of the things that fascinates me the
most are the times that video games
impact on our real-world lives may it's
just kind of talked about which is again
why I was happy the depression quest you
know came up because many people who are
having issues and then don't be another
issue like you know it's part of a lot
of conversations that I always find them
hypnotic so I and the really good thing
so today on the point we're gonna talk
about how development deadlines affect
creativity we're gonna demonstrate so by
creating today's episode in one day
[Music]
hi there good morning and welcome to
Warsaw here in poland's home of said a
project red the team behind the witcher
a gaming franchise based around the
short stories novels of mr. Angiers a
pesky and now one of the most
anticipated games of 2015
[Music]
so put on your best pair of shoes today
we explored the world of wild hogs
[Music]
heavy crate war zones in which acrobatic
pilots and hulking mechanical robots
both have their place today on the next
big game we break apart the anatomy of a
Titan format yeah you sort of have your
fingerprints and essentially like if not
almost on lizards games since since the
early 90s for good or ill
[Music]
[Music]
damn dude ah hmm
[ __ ] you a kid oh thank you so much good
Jesus I don't know how she put that
together we had a long weekend and
everything thank you so much married I
was oh jeez Louise you left in the place
in a different shape and it was when you
got here I mean you've done a lot for
the site man and you've definitely
inspired a lot of us hey we all did
that's why we did it right that's why we
[ __ ] did it because we wanted to like
add to the sign make it like cool like
it was when when we were like looking
from the outside in you know yeah and I
think you did probably more in that
effort than a lot of us are able to
thank you so much I mean that's the only
thing that makes like leaving feel okay
because it's like sucks I would not be
leaving this if it wasn't like the life
and I mean you know when you have a
dream and then like you reach that dream
and then you need to like figure out
what the new dream is and like this site
is giving me everything like I'm like I
met my wife because I moved here like
it's giving me everything so I wouldn't
be moving if I wouldn't be leaving if it
wasn't for for something else that I
felt like I like needed to do yeah so I
love news on all that new stuff whenever
I'm not going anywhere else I'm not
going to any other website or anything
um a massive gamespot fan and I will
leave here and get I get to be a
GameSpot fan again and you know set it
as my home page again you harass me in
the comments yeah exactly I mean that's
like that's that's what happens to
everyone who leaves here like that's
what we've got you know Josh Shaw and
Dan work in the chat like Chris is in
the chat like we're all fans of this
place and like even after we leave like
that that shows you how how much this
place means to people that you know they
stay connected even though even though
we're gone like even when we had Kevin
in here a couple of months ago you know
it's just like this place in
it's like brands itself on you not just
because of what the name of the site and
what the site means to people but just
because the people who are here you know
and that's what I'm gonna miss the most
right by mile look it's not goodbye it's
not it's not around its CEO ranch I'm
gonna be in here recording a podcast
performing the one every Tuesday
probably look at us that'll make things
so hot where´s - and who knows like you
know who knows maybe we'll well well you
know we'll maybe I'll do a hot collabo
every now and again or something and you
know and long in the future feature but
uh yeah
alright I guess if this is by the last
live show I want to thank everyone I
want to thank God I want to thank rich
Gallup and Jeff Gerstmann and Ryan
McDonald and Vinnie Caravela for making
me want to do this in the first place um
Chris Beaumont and Ben Howard
[ __ ] Ford he's taking a risk on
me you know I applied for the job a
bunch of times and didn't get it and
those were the guys who who believed in
me and shepherded me through this so
thanks dude Andy Bauman my creative best
creative partner I ever had who if it
wasn't for him none of that stuff would
have looked as good as it did and then
everyone here you guys everyone in the
back too many people to mention you know
here who are here right now and who are
who have gone over the years and thank
you so much and of course to everyone
for watching this stuff cuz without you
guys
I never what accountant GameSpot I never
would have gone to America I never would
have been able to take the next leap so
thank you all so much and if it's the
morning where you are I'm sorry if you
cried cuz it's [ __ ] this is quite first
and go back to bastards if you're in the
UK go to bed
[Music]